first the furlough scheme
will be extended until the end of
september
for employees there will be no change to
the terms
they will continue to receive 80 of
their salary
for hours not worked until the scheme
ends
as businesses reopen we will ask them to
contribute alongside the taxpayer
to the cost of paying their employees
nothing will change
until july when we will ask for a small
contribution
of just 10 and 20 in august
and september the government is proud
of the furlough one of the most generous
schemes in the world
effectively protecting millions of
people's jobs
and incomes second
support for the self-employed will also
continue
until september with a fourth grant
covering the period february to april
and a fifth and final grant from may
onwards
the fourth grant will provide three
months of support at
eighty percent of average trading
profits for the fifth grant
people will continue to receive grants
worth three months of
average profits with the system open for
claims
from late july but as the economy
reopens over the summer
it is fair to target our support
towards those most affected by the
pandemic
so people whose turnover has fallen by
30
or more will continue to receive the
full
80 percent grant people whose turnover
has fallen by less than 30 percent will
therefore have less need
of taxpayer support and will receive
a 30 grand and i can also announce a
major improvement in
access to the self-employed scheme
when the scheme was launched the newly
self-employed couldn't qualify
because they hadn't all filed the 1920
tax return
but as the tax return deadline has now
passed
i can announce today that provided they
filed a tax return by midnight last
night
over 600 000 more people
many of whom became self-employed last
year can now claim the fourth
and fifth grants